JAMES GRIME: OK, so,
the superflip--
so let me write down the
superflip for you.
Rubik's cube fans have a
notation, and they call this
the up, they call this the
down, they call this the
right-hand side--
for obvious reasons-- the
left-hand side, the front,
which is facing me--
and the back, which is facing
away from me there.
So it's got up, down, left,
right, front, and back.
I can write down the superflip
using this idea.
It's going to take 20 moves.
I'm going to write down what the
20 moves are, then we'll
try it out.
Looks like this--
up.
So I'm going to turn
the up once.
Now, this means right-hand
side twice--
once, twice.
Front--
that's towards me--
once.
Back-- that's over here.
That's the back--
right.
Right-hand side again.
Back twice.
Look at it there.
Oh, one, two that one too.
Right.
Up twice--
one, two.
Left--
back twice--
one, two.
Right--
"U" dash-- that means the
opposite direction--
anticlockwise.
Down--
Right-hand side twice.
Front.
Right-hand side backwards.
Left.
Bottom twice--
once, twice.
Up twice--
And then do the front twice,
so once, twice.
Look at that.
So there are 20 moves
there, and this was
superflip, the cube.
From the solved state, you get
this really pretty combination
there, and this is the furthest
away from being
solved that you can get.
Now, if you look at it, what's
happened is all the corners
are perfectly fine.
You see, this is the
orange face.
All the orange corners and
the center are just fine.
This is the orange face.
Look at the edge pieces.
This is the orange-white edge,
and it's flipped over.
Turn it 'round.
This is the orange-blue edge,
and it's flipped over.
This is the orange-yellow edge,
which is flipped over.
And that's the orange-green
edge, and that's flipped over.
So all the edge pieces
flip over.
All the corners are absolutely
fine, and the centers are
always fine.
They don't move at all.
There's a couple of cool things
about this superflip
that I haven't told you yet.
So if I do the superflip
twice--
so the superflip was 20 moves.
If I do it twice, I will get
back to where I started.
In mathematics, we say
it has order 2.
You do it twice, and you'll get
back to where you started.
So that's pretty cool.
The other cool thing about the
superflip is that if I do a
bunch of moves, and then I do
the superflip, you'll get the
same answer as if you do the
superflip first, and then you
do that bunch of moves.
So you'll get the same answer.
So if you do superflip first,
and stuff, or if you do stuff
first, and superflip, you'll get
the exact same position.
In fact, superflip is the only
move that isn't just doing
nothing at all.
It's the only move that
has that property.
MALE SPEAKER: Because I would
have thought that would be
true for everything,
but it's not.
JAMES GRIME: It's not
true for everything.
Now, that's really important.
So if I do a move followed
by another
move, the order matters.
The order matters.
You get a different answer if
you do it in a different
order, if you swap those over,
except for the superflip.
Only the superflip--
this works.
The order doesn't matter.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, whoa--
lock up.
No!
Wha--
oh, man.